you'll hear me use the word abstract a
lot so i thought i would actually give
you an attempt at a definition or maybe
more even more important an intuition of
what abstract means an abstract it can
be an adjective you could have an
abstract idea you can you can have
abstract art or it can be a verb you can
abstract something abstract the idea
from some other idea and you can even
have it as a noun you can have an
abstract and it tends to when you use it
as a noun the one that i tend to
associate is the abstract of a research
paper which is kind of distills the
essence of the research papers kind of a
summary of that paper and the one thing
you're going to see regardless of how
you what context you you use the word
abstract there's this kind of notion of
taking the essence of a real world of of
a of a real world object whether you use
it as a noun an adjective or a verb so
over here we have our real world
we have our real world and then over
here you have your world of you have
ideas
ideas and concepts and the general idea
behind abstraction or abstracting
something is you're taking it away from
the particular concrete real world and
you're going more in the direction of
ideas and concepts and probably for me
one of the the most tangible ways of
thinking about abstraction which is kind
of a
you know a contradiction in itself to
think of abstraction in a tangible way
is things is things like geometric
shapes so if we were if i were so if i
were to tell you find me some cubes you
might point to a borg vessel right over
there
a borg vessel you might point to you
might point to
maybe a pair of dice so let me draw the
pair of dice
if you are looking for cubes
so you might point to a pair of dice
that looks something like
that you might point to a rubik's cube
anything that you could find there might
be a building that looks like a cube
there might be a building that looks
like a cube or maybe there's a box in
your house that is a cube
but in your mind you have a general idea
of what a cube is you're like well i
know a cube when i see one and that
general idea is essentially distilling
the concept the idea of what a cube is
all of these things are very different
this is some plastic thing that i can
hold in my hand these are these little
white things and they're not even you
know geometrically even close to being
perfect they have these little divots on
the side right over there this is a
large borg vessel that you know it
doesn't even exist yet it's not you know
obviously it's a fictional thing but
they they all have this cubeness to them
and this is one of the fun things of
geometry is to really distill the
essence of these these these real world
shapes
and we do have a definition in geometry
which is an object like this
i guess you could have an object like
this where every side has the exact same
length so this if this is length one
then that would be length one that is
length one but it doesn't have to be
whatever the length this side is in this
dimension then in this dimension is
going to be that length and that
dimension is going to be in that length
and i'm not giving you the rigorous
geometric definition but i'm just trying
to highlight that there is a pure idea
of what a cube is
of what a cube is and in the real world
there is nothing that is actually a
perfect cube if you were to get really
really close to these die if you were to
really try to measure exactly their
measurements they won't be exactly the
same measurement but in
the the abstract idea of a cube this is
ide is completely the same length as
this and this and actually this and all
of the edges are going to have the exact
same length so this is going from the
concrete the specific from the real
world if you consider the 24th or 25th
century the real world to going to
going to the idea behind it the general
idea and you've probably also heard the
word abstract in terms of art like
abstract art
so this is abstract art and it's the
same general idea if you look it up on a
dictionary you're going to find 20
definitions of the word abstract but
it's all essentially trying to say the
same thing
abstract art is art that is not focused
on trying to paint reality the exact way
that reality exists if you look at kind
of a lot of you know renaissance art
they're skilled at painting figures
exactly how they look in the real world
but the abstract artists sometimes
they're not even trying to even
represent anything that's in the real
world they're trying to represent a raw
idea or they're trying to represent a
raw expression of color and form and
texture and this is a jackson pollock
painting right over here and i
pronounced many many things wrong this
was taken by our own steven zucker art
historian and as you can see it's not
clear jackson pollock is not trying to
paint you know a dog or a horse or
anything like that he is painting
something that is devoid it's completely
independent of anything that we actually
see in physical reality
and the word abstraction you know i'm
you know it doesn't just apply to you
know pure geo geometry and art it
applies to almost everything that we do
on a daily basis when we even talk about
things when we even use words or use
symbols we're essentially abstracting
away we're abstracting the essence of of
something that actually exists in
physical reality so if i use the word if
i use the word dog
it's a set of symbols this set of
symbols represents something in our
minds that we associate with dog we have
in our minds kind of the qualities of
what a dog actually is you know it has
it has four legs and floppy ears and you
enjoy petting it and they're they're
man's or i guess people's best friend
you imagine this thing called a dog and
it has the essence of dogness even
though when you actually look at dogs in
the real world they look very very very
different
types of animals whether you're looking
at a great dane or a or a
or kind of a super small poodle but we
we recognize there's an essence of those
particulars that we can abstract away
and say this is a dog and then we
abstract it even more by representing
these letter symbols that tend to
conjure up this image even when we write
something as simple as a number so if i
write if i write the number 5
we use it so frequently that we just to
us a number 5 seems kind of like a
concrete thing but it's so abstract it's
just a quantity a quantity of things i
could have symbolized it like that i
could have symbolized five like that i
could have symbolized five in roman
numerals like that i can symbolize it
like that and in all of these cases they
are it's the idea of a quantity of five
things five you know if we were you know
you could say point me to a five someone
would probably draw point you to
something like that but they're still
pointing you to the symbol of of five
but it's still a very very abstract idea
so hopefully this gives you an
appreciation for what abstract means as
you can tell you know it's kind of a
for lack of a better word it's kind of a
an abstract idea
not to make be too cute about that